good morning strange loot whoa
ask yourself this what do I truly care
about is it improving the throughput of
my web server is it even will I be able
to use Haskell on my next project is it
even anything about work at all what
about where my next holiday will be I
don't know for many of us I think it's
actually these guys despite the fact
that our children are incredibly labor
intensive despite the fact that they
drive us to levels of exhaustion
frustration and sometimes I'm ashamed to
say anger that we never believed
ourselves capable of even so they are
somehow integral to ourselves and we
treat them that we treat their
development and flourishing as one of
the most important things in in their
lives in our lives and that's what I
want and in particular I think those of
us worth or not we our parents we would
all think of ourselves as having a
responsibility to give our children our
nation's children our world children all
of them and a really good education to
equip them for lives of richness and
complexity and that's what I want to
speak about today particularly about
computing it's a great joy to be at
Strange Loop at last I wanted to come
from years but actually it is my
children who have they've taken a lot of
my time and attention so I've not made
it before but I'm thrilled to be here
I'm going to speak from a UK perspective
but this story about the reform of
computing education is a is a journey
that everybody around the world is on
and there's nobody has a monopoly on
truth I hope that some of the
reflections that I've made they're
thinking we've done in UK we'll have
some resonance for you and I shall be
here all today to to talk to if you'd
like to talk to me afterwards so let's
start here it's good to frame things in
an ambitious way this is a quote from
Richard Wylie who was a Secretary of
Education in the United States and he
said education should prepare young
people for jobs that do not yet exist
using technologies that have not yet
been invented to solve problems of which
we are not yet aware and this is very
real for me today but my son Michael who
was 28 has recently taken a job with IO
HK working on blockchain which
didn't exist when we were talking about
computing education around the dining
room table 15 years ago so how do we do
this well at school we typically teach
children something about subject
disciplines and something about skills
so by disciplines I mean things like
ideas knowledge theorems methods
subjects like mathematics science
history and English those are only in
the subject discipline camp in the
skills camp we have we if they're
generally skills it to do the artifacts
devices programs products organizations
stuff that we have made and how to
operate them in a you know confident in
safe manner so we might think about
presentation skills about metalwork
about textiles all of these are good
things too and schools typically do both
so what has happened in computing well
in the UK at least in the 2000s this is
the story we had a subject called
information and communication technology
so way there was part of the curriculum
that was about our our stuff but it but
there was no notion of a subject
discipline it was at its worst will
teach children how to use Microsoft
Office and even Microsoft didn't want
that so one and moreover by the
mid-2000s children mainly knew at some
level already they weren't necessarily
good there was no notion of subject
discipline so what's the there was in
short too much focus on technology and
not enough on ideas right indeed the
clue is in the title information and
communication technology you know we're
kind of from the out of the starting
gate we're doing this long so what's the
obvious thing to do well trying to put
the discipline back into the subject and
to bring it back into balance so here is
the the vision if you like the
enterprise in which I think we are
engaged we'd like to make computer
science into a foundational subject
discipline that all children that like
mathematics and Natural Science all
children learn from primary school
onwards as I guess elementary school
here so that's that's a big vision we
need to sort of flesh it out a bit if
we're going to sell listen and speak
about it to ourselves and to our our
nation's we need to say a bit more about
what we might mean by that so what I'm
going to do quickly is to just for her
for you the story that we now tell in
the UK about what computer science is
and why we might want to teach it in the
hope that it may help give you vocab
really these are things that have will
ended up being becoming persuasive so
here is the way we characterize
uncomputable that I've come to
characterize computer science think of
it now as a school subject rather than
as a dorky University subject for you
know socially challenged males like and
like me so computer science is the study
of information computation and
communication in both natural and
artificial systems so let's say a little
bit more about each of those things
start with information so here are two
pictures which picture contains more
information well it's a little hard to
say even what that question means but I
might put it like this if I was to be on
the telephone with you and trying to get
you to draw one of these pictures at the
other end of the phone which would be
easier
well the Starlite I could just give you
some coordinates you've enjoyed the Mona
Lisa would take a little bit longer so
there is a reason to say one picture has
more information than the other and as
soon as you do that you get into well
could you measure information what units
might you measure it in right and this
you know get straight in deep into
information theory yeah but at least
it's a whole series of interesting
questions about information like that
leads to you might think about binary in
a less operational way then this is how
computers do arithmetic second thing
computation so this is what most people
think about when they think about
computers in computer science again it's
helpful to have examples I often use the
Traveling Salesman problem here it is
finder you know the shortest path
through all the owner the capital them
the state capitals but it's a nice
example because because it's np-complete
nobody knows a way to find the optimal
path within the lifetime of the universe
if you have enough cities and that's
quite a remarkable thing it's kind of
counterintuitive you think computers can
do everything can't they so that's
interesting all by itself
another interesting thing is that you
know though there were these
approximation algorithms simulated
annealing is one which can find really
very good answers really very quickly
and they're really very simple
algorithms so this and there's some real
cleverness there and then you might also
ask intellectually interesting questions
like you know how close does it get how
fast does it 1 ok
he was a young
an example of an algorithm that sorting
algorithms that is done by my friend Tim
Bell in New Zealand so he does this with
primary school children it's a sorting
algorithm which the children are
standing in front of a network on the
floor and the rules of the game are that
when two children holding a number meter
to box if the six is bigger than the two
so they swap places and move out along
the the the other arcs so and then they
can do this simultaneously so it's a
parallel algorithm executed by primary
school children in their socks and then
you know they they come and all the way
to the end and miraculously they are
sorted and even the Secretary of State
Education you know he gives a little
smile when this happens and you could do
this a competition and you can do it at
a larger scale on the playground Tim
tells me that this 15 seconds of video
took him an entire morning to to achieve
so it is an amazing achievement
so why do I show you this well there's
something clever going on it's clearly
about ideas it can't be about technology
because there is no technology it
encourages experimentation that your
kids might think or maybe the teacher
put it in the right order so he came out
sore dude let's try to fool the teacher
and put ourselves in a different order
oh no matter what we do we still come
out sorted they might ask could we do
the same job with fewer boxes and wires
they might ask could we sort larger
numbers so it's a while some of these
questions are quite deep right it's
there's a sort of experimental you could
just an average ly inquisitive child
could try things out and I really like
that idea
encourages inquisitiveness and curiosity
and it's plainly about ideas okay
communication information computation
communication so again you know
computers communicate a lot so we often
don't think about that so much certainly
when we're teaching it but here's an
example bill and and Bill and Jane have
never met before they're in a crowded
strange loop party with a lot of
eavesdroppers and they want to have a
private conversation if they could have
a secret key but so that they knew and
nobody else knew they could encrypt
their conversation let's take that as
wed but how do they get a secret key
that they share and their eavesdroppers
do not share that seems like impossible
but it's called diffie-hellman key
exchange and your web browser does it
whenever you engage in a secure
transaction on the web so I love it
because it's it's it seems like
something just could not be done but by
clever ideas computer scientists to
figure out how to do it and moreover
figured out how to do it using a level
of mathematics that an average you know
14 to six-year-old 16 year old can do
and it really is a clever algorithm
another thing that's were a point that's
worth making two one two people more
bored is that computer science is quite
interdisciplinary here's an example
which I really like to do with that sort
of crossover between computing and and
English here the rules of the game are
you put your finger on this some of this
thingy and you move it around you follow
you follow an arrow and you say the word
so the old clown and the big pilot sang
and the big
clown laughed and then you got so you've
generating an english-language sentence
so that you show this to children you
get them to generate sentences and then
soon they're writing new diagrams that
generate new sentences usually rude ones
and but of course they're also trying to
generate sentences that kind of makes
sense and so they're in effect
retrospectively reinventing the laws of
grammar but in a fun way and then and
you look at this in the final you can
say well actually this is just the
finite state machine and you could also
use it to describe the states of your
microwave oven which is deeply
mysterious to all people so you know
it's a sort of single idea that is
useful in many in many circumstances and
so there's lots of stuff about in
teaching computing in an
interdisciplinary way so information
computation communication so let me just
tackle a couple of myths so one thing
that lay people being a politician
school leaders will often think is
computing it's about computers isn't it
I love this quote from Dykstra you know
Computer Science to know more about
computers than astronomy is about
telescopes because it's it's a little
bit over the top actually computer
science is a bit more about computers
and astronomy is about telescopes but he
had the right idea right so I keep
saying this ideas not technology and the
that stuff with them boxes was on the
floor it's called unplugged approaches
the teaching computer science I think
it's profoundly helpful as a way to
convey ideas without mixing them up with
technology and also ting this this kind
of thinking is not all about computers
is encourages you to look outside the
the artificial world the built word
world of the sleek devices that we've
grown so used to and look at ants and
cells my colleagues at some Microsoft
Research in Cambridge are doing systems
of biology where they they're really
regard cells as kind of information
processors the DNA is in the program and
they're they're actually these days
they're writing code and when you
compile it the you know the the
execution engine is a cell that's fairly
amazing and so it's a new lens with
which to look at the natural world but
it's not just that level of cells you
can look at the emergent behavior of
ants and bees as they float as they run
around the world with their tiny little
brains that do rather remarkable
collective things so not just about
computers about not it's about
computation and even if you think about
computers secondly these
it's all about coding so you will have
seen a lot of this right so I'm a huge
respect for Bill Gates and actually I
love all of this stuff about why I
always teach our kids to code but it's
not only that right there's a tremendous
amount if you ask the person on the
street what's happening computing they
will say well we should teach teach our
kids to code and we should yes we should
but programming is too computer science
as lab work is to physics that is to say
if you took the lab work out of physics
you would eviscerate the subject you
would leave it as a dull husk of itself
and yet you would not put children in a
lab with inclined planes and ball
bearings and stopwatches
and hope that they reinvented Newton's
laws of motion so programming is super
important but it's also seductive and
distracting and also can encourage a
further you know renewed focus on
technology one of my fears about this
reform of computing education is that in
10 years time education ministers will
be standing up and saying we have solved
the you know the computing crisis we now
teach our kids Python right so we live
unhooked ourselves from one pile of
technology namely in a Microsoft Office
and simply hooked ourselves on a
different pile of technology namely
particular programming language is or
even programming in general does that
make sense
ok all right so next thing we have to
say this is particularly when we're
talking to schools and parents is to say
why is this subject foundational they
might say well look we don't teach law
to every child lawyers we it's a sort of
later stage of Education why do you say
it's foundational every child should
learn it so here is reason number one
the one that I personally find most
persuasive ask yourself this why do we
teach every child physics or biology
every child is it because they are going
to become professional biologists no
only a tiny fraction of them will do
that it's something to do with
understanding the world and having
agency in it by agency I mean some kind
of power some kind of ability to take
control of events rather than be ruled
by them
so I want children to be able to create
compute
a tional things not just consume them I
want them to be able to understand as
well as use the sleek devices that they
find in their pockets and feel so facile
and familiar with and I do want them to
understand that it's just technology
it's not magic
Arthas he can't famously remark that any
form of sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic and I
think it would be very damaging if our
children came to believe in effect that
the devices that they hold are kind of
magic they're made that other people
across the ocean over whom they have no
control and which if they utter
appropriate incantations good things
will happen but if good things do not
happen then they are you know well it's
just magic that's not good that one a
sense of empowerment a second reason to
when teach children teach all children
computing is because it helps for all
our young people to have the knowledge
and skills to undertake the jobs of the
future and lots of them will involve
they may not remain in a mainstream they
may not be the strange Lea boards but
there's an enormous Lea bigger number of
people who need to know something about
computing and this is both good for our
world in our nation's it's also good for
young people to have highly valued
well-paid jobs so you will have seen
diagrams like this I'm not going to
pause here very long just to say that
one message I want you to get here is
it's not just the strange loop audience
here there's an enormous spectrum of
careers in which some knowledge and
again agency in computing is really
important so it's kind of like what
what's what's not to like it's an
intellectually interesting subject it's
deeply engaging as soon as you start to
write programs and you're going to get a
really well-paid job and but the mythos
it's not all about jobs right so it's
about tomorrow's jobs not today's and so
I think that while employers and I think
employers don't want to play a what
should I say normative role the role of
Education is not to produce oven-ready
people popping out at the end of
education ready to just start jobs with
that when needing no further training is
to produce children who have a good
intellectual and resilience toolbox and
problem-solving skills in you know in an
hour so they can survive so they can
deal with successive ways of technology
which will happen to them
okay so two pillars an educational
pillar and a and a kind of instrumental
pillar I say instrumental because it's
about you know make good things for our
world so that's really helpful for
politicians politicians like having a
reason to say it's good for our economy
so I just want to finish this little
section by saying here so here's my a my
sort of positioning then the vision is
on the left but it's sort of nuanced a
bit and I'm just articulated them here
ideas not technology every child not
just the the sort of geeks and not just
a narrow segment of people who become
the software engineers of the future an
educational mission not just an
instrumental one and a subject
discipline not just skills okay and
these things are not you know it's not
an either-or a lot of these things are
in balance I do want children to have
skills particular skills in programming
and problem-solving as well okay okay
[Laughter]
okay so what we going to do about it so
just a very quick resume of what's
happened in Britain so in 2007-8 I was
around the the dining room table of my
children talking about the really
terrible education in ICT that they were
then getting and thinking I can't make a
connection between what they are
learning and the subject that is I think
is so fascinating that I have devoted my
professional life to it so then we
formed computing at school which is kind
of given a group of volunteers to try to
fix this problem we hadn't got a clue
how we voted curriculum then then a
number of things happen at national
level there was a there was a change of
government and the then Secretary of
State or Education Michael Gove
instituted - a view of the whole
National Curriculum that was very
helpful because it meant there was there
was movement in the system there was a
there was a possibility of change a
pivotal moment was when Eric Schmidt who
was the chairman of Google gave a a well
and well reported talk in which he he
said in in Britain he said I am
flabbergasted the good word that I'm
flabbergasted that you do not teach your
children how to program in there you
know in the land of a Babbage and I
thought it's a bit cheeky but it's not
as if every child in United States get
some good programming education either
but nevertheless it's you know I
it made me learn how a few sentences in
a speech by a very able and senior in
this case man can have huge influence it
moved the conversation out of an
educational ghetto into the political
sphere and suddenly our own Prime
Minister then David Cameron was saying
yeah I think we should teach our kids to
code so it was very helpful then the
Royal Society big 400 year old August
institution produced this report that
said what it said all the things I've
been saying that was very helpful
because governments find it much easier
to listen to Big August institutions
than they do to guerilla groups so then
in the end as part of the review of the
National Curriculum the government asked
a couple of professional societies the
British Computer Society in the Royal
Academy of Engineering to draft the new
the new curriculum for computing and I
ended up chairing a working group that
wrote that and the specification was
rather good they said to us you can say
whatever you like Simon but
has to fit on two sides of a four for
ten years of Education in computing that
focuses the mind wonderfully so here it
is it's readily available I'll give you
a link at the end but these are the aims
of the the English National Curriculum
for computer science and I'm still quite
proud of them and I know I would say
that but look every child should be able
to understand and apply the fundamental
principles of computer science including
logic algorithms are so forth every
child can analyze problems in
computational terms and have repeated
practical experience of writing programs
to solve them and then the other two
aims are more applied so we're not
throwing the baby out with the bathwater
so this I think is the first time any
country has really embodied such clarity
about computers answers of subject
discipline from primary school onwards
alongside other subject disciplines now
at that stage we thought well job done
right it's it's the National Curriculum
we can go home and but but we but we
could not and so it's it's it's easy to
think that once you've written a
curriculum it all be fine but actually
the you know turning curriculum into a
living reality in every classroom in
that in the land is a huge challenge
teachers are under-qualified mostly they
do not have a computing qualifications
it's like introducing an entirely new
subject into the school curriculum
there's never been taught there before
and schools too under intense pressure
from lots of directions anyway so
computing is really not front and center
on their radar at all so it turns out to
be a much bigger challenge so it was a
still bigger challenge than getting it
onto the curriculum let me pull so just
for a moment to say we reflect briefly
on how did we get it even to that point
because these may have these these sort
of lessons that we learn they have an
resonance for you one thing we had a
very singular focus it was computer
science as part of that vision that I
said that was our focus was an
educational message not just an
instrumental one we've tried very hard
to speak with one voice if politicians
and other other leaders get lots of
conflicting messages from different
interest groups in say the tech
community they will not know what to
think if they hear a single voice that's
much easier for them to pay attention
- and I was helpful the computing at
school was the kind of grassroots
independent group it didn't speak for
higher education it didn't speak for
employers it didn't speak for teachers
it was a sort of broad church that was
very helpful it was really helpful to
have support from professional bodies
and like the Royal Society it was really
helpful to have support from industry
and it was a place where I'm very proud
to say that even though Microsoft and
Google compete like you know fiercely at
product level there's
shoulder-to-shoulder on education they
go to the government together it's
really helpful we didn't wait for the
policy to change we just got on with it
and I think that's very helpless if you
wait for policy to change you'll just
you know die of old age just get on with
it and I have to say that we were lucky
like mark oh yeah I we didn't cause
Michael go to make a review of the
National Curriculum we were really lucky
about that okay so what has happened
like about all this so it's it's a
challenge and three years in 2009 were
last year the same Royal Society
produced another report this is cool
this is it well this is the summary the
actual report is a lot longer it's
called after the reboot and it's a state
of the nation summary of how things are
going it's readily available online it's
quite entertaining we - you might like
to look at it and it paints a very
patchy picture lots to celebrate but
lots to worry about - you know a small
proportion of the schools offering GCSE
here means GCSE means the aged 16
national examinations so only a very
small proportion of our children are
taking oh a child might typically take
about ten GCSEs but only one in ten
students is even taking a computer
science as one of their ten subjects
terrible gender imbalance as as word
terribly familiar with but maybe this
would help like we start earlier maybe
we can help to address the the
tremendous gender imbalance in computing
and very inadequate professional
development so there was a very helpful
report to one to just sort of give an
independent assessment of how things
were going exam examinations are not in
a good shape I shall pause here teacher
recruitment is difficult unsurprisingly
teaching is a very challenging job it's
inspiring but it's very challenging and
if you're computer scientists well
people are
doing up at your door to stuff your
mouth with gold are they not
so I'm thankful that some people just in
their hearts know that they want to be
teachers and some of them are computer
scientists but not enough so maybe some
of you there are people who are leaving
the tech sector in order to become
teachers now because at last we're
teaching computer science at school okay
so I want to spend just a few minutes on
the kind of things that we might do at
this stage having got you know and and
this is true in many countries in the
world in many countries there's maybe it
hasn't got the this run of every child
from primary school onward stuff but
there's a lot of motion in many
countries so what can we as a you know
tech community do to help so here are
the things again this is these are the
things that we did that helped for us
one thing was to form a community of
practice a kind of grassroots movement
just of individuals not very
institutional this to just try to push
things forward it's all computing at
school and it's very much not it's not
like a subscription organization no you
pay your subscription and you get
services and you know and benefits in
exchange now you should think of
computing school like an open source
project right it's you bring you know
some expertise and ideas to the table
and you get to share those with many
other people who engaged in a common
endeavor you know it's a bit anarchic
it's not the maybe even it's not very
well led but it's kind of you know we're
on a mission from God to do something
important that's the the zeitgeist of
cows we young we started a lot of
physically local hubs Britain is a
fairly small country and it's densely
populated that's easier for us to have
get teachers physically together that's
very helpful
we built a large corpus of online
resources crowdsource them so we made it
very easy to be able to upload stuff of
course that means we've got a lot of
stuff and not all of it is great but the
the barrier to entry is low and that was
the choice that we made we trained quite
a lot of teachers to become teacher
trainers themselves so we gave them
training and then the deal was that they
would then train other teachers in their
local neighborhood so it's very the
message they won't want to get you as
grassroots see we also develop some
central resources here are some these
are CPD means
professional development so this means
teacher training stuff
Casas very much organized around
supporting the teachers we do know pupil
facing no child facing activities we
reckon we can we can train the teachers
we'll be doing well very young we
partnered with the Raspberry Pi
foundation fantastic organization also
based in Cambridge to one to develop
hello world this is a the latest issue
of but not this is an issue of hello
world it's a magazine written by
teachers for teachers and available you
know available for free online to
everybody and actually two for free in
print form two teachers in the UK and
elsewhere in the world so it's got very
high production values do do take a look
it's quite inspiring actually because it
gives you a little window into the life
of a teacher I read this and I think wow
these guys are just amazing but other
other magazines have beamed this has
been around for longer than Kazakhs do
have a look at CS for fun so it's a lot
of resources now available that's not
our problem it's a shortage of resources
one thing that we did not do so well
that if you're doing this in your
country I advise you to pay more
attention to is getting high stakes
examinations right high stakes national
examinations flushes is age 16 and age
18 Drive everything in the schools they
drive school behavior drives teacher
behavior parent paper pupil behavior
everything you can have the best
curriculum in the world if you're if
you're high stakes exams are screwed up
your education system will be screwed up
so it's worth paying attention and I
feel we didn't pay attention to to this
early enough and we're still sort of
dealing with fallout from that but it's
difficult because they're high stakes so
changing them is hard and it's rife with
unintended consequences
third thing getting alongside teachers
so teachers are genuinely I say this in
a heartfelt way they are our heroes and
heroines they are doing amazing jobs in
the classroom and we should love and
support them and not make them feel
ignored or overwhelmed or sidelined or
marginalized as or or still less you
know we've got this new subject and
you're a crappy old teacher so you're on
the scrap people going to find shiny new
teachers to do this
you know we have to sit alongside our
teachers and and help support and
equipment to do an incredible job and
but it is hard everything's in flux we
don't have much experience about
pedagogy so being a teacher particularly
in computing is a tough job as one
teacher put put it to me they could kind
of feel isolated there might be the only
computing teacher of their school she
said it's me or me or me and that's
quite hard so that's what that that's
why the community of practice is so
important
so since computing is really is a new
subject that we're teaching at school we
do have an obligation to offer
substantive training to our teachers and
that does cost money so finally with the
that that's there's just no way out of
it we I think and government should do
this but maybe you know maybe the tech
sector has to help us well we've
certainly invested lots and lots of
effort in training and supporting
teachers but it's because there are a
lot of teachers you need a lot of boots
on the ground this is a scale problem
but hey people in this room know about
scale
another thing research so mathematicians
have centuries of experience in how to
teach mathematics and they are still not
agreed about what the best way to do it
is we have about three weeks well maybe
you know three years or five years we
just have much less experience about how
to teach computer science we have quite
a lot at university but still you know
only two or three decades worth but it's
cool much less and universities and
schools are different teaching contexts
so I love this paper for example by Mark
goose DL in which he says the notch of
the way you'd think about teaching
programming and the way that a lot of
universities do teach programming is a
succession of problems in which they say
here's the blank sheet of paper write a
program to you know add up to numbers
right a program to and up a lot of
numbers or Ida began through this right
but at each stage its start from a blank
sheet of paper and he did expansion but
she said oh if in which instead he
showed he got students to look at
existing programs and modify understood
how they worked expand them to other
people to him motley scaffolded the
entire PI's in a different way got much
better results so this is kind of thing
who know that
then why would you do it the other way
right so we really need to study how to
teach in rather than have our individual
teachers sort of learning it by gut feel
in their own classrooms that's just nuts
but again it costs money so the the last
thing I want to just mention by we're
things we can do is some to do with
formative assessment now this is a
project that I've been personally
involved it's will project quantum and I
actually think that it could be could be
amazing so here's the idea every teacher
has to come to an opinion about how
their students are getting on if you've
got ten students you can have a pretty
good intuitive feeling if you have five
hundred students you have to have some
way some more systematic way of doing it
so what do you do you probably set them
tests of some kind this isn't the end of
semester test that says have you passed
or failed have you flunked the course
this is the you know and putting a
thermometer in your mouth at the end of
the week to see you know have you are
you running a fever do you understand
the stuff that we've been doing this
week or not and if not what are your
misconceptions and how could I help so
it's very much
formative that is it's part of the
learning process not summative that is
metrics on a cheat levels of achievement
do you get the difference super
important so quantum is all about
formative assessment so what actually
happens though is teachers make up these
questions which is bonkers because
number one good questions are hard to
write if you are an expert if you are
not an expert and is struggling with the
subject they are super hard to write you
have to mark them that's not good that
increases your workloads and worst of
all this is happening in every school
and what a huge waste of human energy
and results of teachers who are really
very hard-pressed so the obvious idea is
why don't we build a corpus of you know
online corpus of questions that are of
high quality and that can be shared by
teachers you know in any country this
year in the next and in fact um you
could do this across subjects and as
well as being a useful resource it would
also have a sort of side effect of the
National Curriculum in its two sides of
a4 remember
so--that's uses compressed technical
language it like use computational
abstractions to understand the real
world you know what on earth does that
mean so if you'd say here's 50 questions
if your students are good at answering
those questions you're probably doing a
reasonable job of teaching that part of
the curriculum that will be really
helpful so it's not an incarnate what
the subject is that's really helpful and
teach of course can do them themselves
so project quantum is about doing
exactly this so we've gathering a corpus
of questions rather than paying experts
to write them we're crowdsourcing them
so that teachers can write their own
questions that's helpful because often
teachers have their own way of doing
things and you know some existing corpus
is not going to do everything that they
want their only multiple choice
questions which I was very sniffy about
to begin with but in this project we've
got you know international level
assessment experts involved and they've
given me a crash course in assessment
research which says that multiple-choice
questions well posed an incredibly good
way of promoting learning they are not
just for babies I don't have time to
tell you all about that but it is just
just believe this is this is something
that's worth studying so it's it's not
just for babies so and the last piece is
crowdsource questions what are we going
to do about quality because many of them
will not be very good remember they're
written by teachers who are not experts
so what can we do about that well it
turns out that assessment experts have
been studying this for a long time let
me put it by this suppose you have
millions of answers written by thousands
of students or hundreds of thousands of
students to thousands of questions then
if you knew how strong each student was
which we don't but suppose you did then
you could discover which were the good
questions but they would discriminate
strong students from weak ones and you
could say for each question not only
whether it was good but if it was good
how hard it is was that's where the knee
and the curve would be okay nod does
that seem plausible okay but if you okay
but we don't know how strong each
student is if we knew which were the
good questions and how hard each of them
was we could figure out which the good
student how strong each student was was
we just give them good questions
and look at which ones they could answer
but we don't know that either so what
should we do
well now it's obvious isn't it we just
solve a simultaneous statistical
equation this is called vash analysis
and yet the sort of best fitting model
that will then who will best explain the
data that we see in the more data we
have than what the better our model is
going to be and so nobody's really try
to do rash analysis at this kind of
scale this is not an international scale
want a single corpus of questions with
you know millions of students more than
the world doing it so really rewards
scale so you get plots like this with
this is the answers to the multiple
choice question the horizontal axis is
student's ability this is a good
question because it does discriminate
good students some weak ones so what
happens over here the you know the
weakest weaker students start are all
going for a when actually the answer I
hope is deep ok so that's quite a
promising idea so that the we've
assembled a corpus of 8,000 odd
questions covering primary and secondary
and covering there all of computing not
just computer science very much focused
on low stakes and absolutely and Phooey
with a guarantee that sort of freed
forever so it's all Creative Commons
license so my reason for advertising
this too is that there's nothing UK
specific about this these questions can
be used anywhere in the world and let
you make they would be packaged
differently you would put them in
quizzes differently but I think it's I
think it could be could be
seismic if we can get the virtue a
circle of scale right have more not it's
it's big so more people come to it so
they add more things and we get more
data to get better quality metrics if
that virtuous circle who knows that
could be amazing
sorry this is just a bee in my bonnet
it's a good B ok so we've talked about
this quite a bit but we we do actually
need to do something about it and
together so casas informal slogan is
this
there is no then there is only us and
what does that mean there isn't a sort
of smoothly humming bureaucracy of well
qualified educational and computing
experts who are beavering a way to you
know write brilliant resources and train
teachers around the country it's not
happening right so there's really only
us and gathered you know
in this room there is more intellectual
horsepower creative enthusiasm and
leadership capacity in this room than
any other single room I have ever spoken
in collectively just the people in this
room have the capacity to move the
needle at national scale but to do that
we actually have to roll up our sleeves
and do something and there are lots of
ways you can do that so couldn't them
you know put some of them here just
finding a school talking to the teachers
getting alongside them as an ally it's
an incredible thing run some kind of
support mechanism for teachers in a
local area I know a hub to do and teach
them a course about something they are
interested in learning write or develop
resources find local companies and tell
them how they can help there's a lot of
organizations I want to talk about in a
second and the way you can you know you
can serve as a member of an organization
and start a coke club or coderdojo
you could just joining cars and
subscribing to hello world that's a good
good first step you know get get a copy
of it and well use quantum write but I
do want to say don't reinvent the wheel
right so there are lots of amazing
organizations doing really astonishingly
brilliant things so I put something here
this code.org Co Club International the
Computer Science Teachers Association in
this country the amazing bootstrap
program run out of Brown University the
Raspberry Pi foundation is has an
international focus and is not just a
it's not that's not laws bleep I the
company that makes raspberry PI's this
is the educational foundation that has
been you know is funded by Wells bloop
Isis brilliant organization
teals have you heard of teals some of
you this is a program in which people
from the tech sector actually teach
class you get quite a lot of training
you teach class in high schools around
I think principally in the United States
at the moment coder dojos a-- as many of
you will know us on a weekend or evening
programming camps for children and their
parents so it's really important to work
and alongside and with and there's
members of these organizations find out
what's going on in your area rather than
to start something entirely new that
risk
crossing over so don't reinvent the
wheel okay but it is important it's no
good I think being passive waiting for
somebody to tell us what to do we have
to be proactive you sit there and wait
for somebody to give you simple
instructions for what to do you'll
probably be waiting a long time you have
to sort of make the running while still
being you know a you know collaborative
partner and one of these things but it
means taking initiatives that's what I
mean by proactive and it does need
sustained input so if you as it were
parachute into a school and then three
weeks later something you know something
urgent has come up a new parachute out
again
you haven't really helped in fact you
might have even harmed so it's easier
doing some of these things together with
other people because making a sustained
commitment for a single individual is
hard right so if you can partner with a
group or better still you know with your
company and make a you know a corporate
commitment to do something that you know
under under their umbrella and with
their blessing that's really helpful the
other little caveat I want to add is
that education is complicated it is rife
with unintended consequences so it's
hard to get things right and we will
fail and we must be humble and accept
that we fail and also humble and listen
to what other people with other points
of view are saying to us we you know we
may be on a mission to change the face
of computing education but that doesn't
entitle us the steam whirl of everybody
else you have to listen very carefully
but the thing I really want to finish up
with just you know do something do
something
as a result of today I just wanted to
finish by and there's one by returning
to our children give you one tiny cameo
one child I found very heartening this
was a workshop held in London which at
this this chap here is Myles Barry who
ran the workshop and one of the children
from a primary school who came was here
called M who was working on a this is a
M kind of total graph its kind of
program and she spotted that she could
take Oh drat this um this sequence of
commands and turned it into a loop she
spotted it and she told some of the
students in her group and that moment of
insight meant that later and
subsequently her teacher wrote this
here I have a self-esteem going through
the roof those associated this is his
words compared to this computing success
with mathematics over the last couple of
weeks you've solved maths problems
problem after problem met target after
touch is truly flying along that's what
this is about what's that that that kind
of sense of agency and empowerment that
this young woman was suddenly went from
thinking thinking you know I can do this
I can make this computer do something
you know you know in a more modular and
brief and elegant way than it did it
before I find that really harming I
don't know do you don't you get that
feeling
so this is where I want to finish right
so it really is about our children I
want our children to be engaged and
curious about this amazing computational
informational and communicational world
that surrounds them I want them to be
empowered informed citizens with agency
feeling that they can they can do things
in the world rather than their first
somebody who's done - I want them to
feel creative and playful about this
stuff they'd be excited by the
intellectual ideas that surround them
rather than worn down by the that you
know the tasks right and yes I do want
them to have a job and I think this will
give them that as well so here is a
here's a link to a lot of pointers to
other stuff I'm sorry to bother well the
weird kind of link but there you go and
so it's my sort of launchpad for a lot
of pointers to this kind of stuff and
they're all finished thank you very much
okay thank you so much I do have some
questions I'm gonna ask them to Simon he
can answer so the mini school districts
you have children laptops or Chromebooks
as a way to help teach tech is what's
your opinion on oh one laptop per child
yes yes so this is a slide I didn't put
in there's a there's a um there's a
whole different strand of Education to
do with using educational technology
including you know a laptop or a tablet
as a way to improve education generally
to teach and learn better across any
subject be it history or science or
mathematics and all computing so this is
I call technology enhanced learning I
think it's really good in the school
where I'm the young where I was for a
long time the chair of the the Board of
Governors for the high school in my area
and we indeed introduced tablets one per
child into chesterton about five years
ago been a huge success but we should
not confuse this sort of horizontal
slice of using technology carefully you
have to be careful you can you can mess
this up too right carefully to improve
teaching and learning across the
curriculum with a kind of the subject
discipline focus that I've been speaking
about in this talk and it's awfully easy
to confuse those but we speak about this
and people hear this and and that can
lead to misunderstandings the you know
app that you best just get rid of those
misunderstandings somehow so yeah I'm
gonna execute my editorial control here
and ask things slightly out of the
ranking order question there's a billion
dollar children's literature industry to
promote motivate reading outside of
school what come on play an analogous
role for computer science to promote
what outta school well the the point is
that there's a there's this giant
industry of children's literature to
teach reading what's the analogy
computer science oh I don't know that's
a good question so there's quite a lot
of out of school Club stuff going
coder dojos an example code club is
another I guess what a Minecraft is
another to really and some of these have
been and some some teachers have
actually adopted my crafter trying to
teach computing through it so I don't
know whether that's really where the
shoe is pinching as it were I think
there's quite a lot of with engaging
resources for how to schoolwork and
really good organizations that are doing
it I think the focus of what what would
at least what I'm interested in they
saying can we move that and put in the
classroom as part of what we try part of
the education we try to give our
children so nobody to think of it as
this and sometimes you look round a
classroom or a room full of children who
are working on computers and they're
highly engaged but you have to think
what are they learning so teachers
always think what are they learning so I
want I want to move on engagement to
learn which is not to denigrate this
other stuff at all fantastic and builds
enthusiasm but I really wanted to be at
school there's a question of do you
think we should also be working you
teach adults about the fundamental
principles of computer science Oh should
we teach adults yes absolutely
yes I mean what's not to like it just so
exciting such an interesting subject
right so yes I mean we have adult
classes in history and medieval Japanese
poetry definitely computing right maybe
we could have like a conference or
something yeah and actually yeah yeah
parents do struggle with this stuff
because they you know they think their
children know more than they do is there
room for a more fundamental subject that
covers rational thinking and philosophy
as a prerequisite oh would rational
thinking and philosophy my Martin
Michael that same that same Michael
who's now at Iowa okay did take a course
called critical thinking in this sort of
age 14 to 16 so it was kind of like
philosophy I don't think I would make it
to prerequisite because remember I want
to start all this at age six but I do
think that computing can be a great way
to to think about thinking indeed
Seymour Papert there's a famous Seymour
Papert quote in which because he's young
which he describes children who
- like logo programs he says they are
you know doing something epistemology
stemologica lee amazing they are
thinking about thinking so I think there
are there are good links said I'm not
sure why I don't think I would make it a
pact was it for to answer questions
directly but thinking skills absolutely
I mean every subject likes to say we
teach you good thinking skills but in
the case of computing it's really true
in the u.s. it seems like everything is
a battle for teaching time how to make
the case for CS learning when we're
struggling to teach math and other
things yes so this is this is a
challenge right so there's only so many
hours in the teaching day so at a
tactical level it's it's
counterproductive to get into a sort of
battle with the mathematicians a sort of
zero-sum game so in in Britain we were
lucky but we had this subject called ICT
so we could sort of repurpose it if that
doesn't exist at all so you're fighting
for space that is a hard one I don't
have a pat answer to that I have
wondered a lot whether it might be
interesting to try to teach mathematics
in computing as a you know as a single
subject rather than having a math silo
in a computing silo but that would be
quite challenging that would really mean
not teaching really teaching maths with
a few genuine flexions to computing or
vice versa it would mean that they were
really hand in glove and that would take
a an exceptional teacher so I don't know
how to do that either I don't have it I
don't have no patent so except that you
know somehow we want our children to
have a good education and we must figure
that out
so so I think this will this would be
the last question how have coding boot
camps affected education and the UK is
that is they too focused on programming
versus computer science camps yeah you
say I think boot camps and sort of sort
of out-of-school camps that we get for
encourage people to do programming have
had a you know a huge effect for
probably actually for the more
privileged slice of children so it's not
it's not very good for inclusion usually
though try it hard though they would try
to get children from diverse backgrounds
that's another thing about mainstream
education it's every child that's very
super important so I think you know
wonderful and you know I'm filled with
admiration for people like bootstrap who
do lots of this after school education
stuff but you know but but it's not
enough and we have to we have to fix
this and we can I should say
particularly in the States the cave k12
CSI put there like there's a big work on
building curriculum part of the common
core curriculum in this country so that
computing can be computer science can be
part of the you know then the extent to
which you have a national curriculum
which is not at all
but there's this common core thing it's
computing is moving into the Common Core
so lots of stuff is happening in this
country too okay I think we're time
great go to it so much do something